okay today I'm going to talk to you
about estimating the rate of
transpiration so as a quick recap
transpiration just means water loss from
a plant there's another video that you
can watch that's just about
transpiration by itself so here's the
plant that we're going to be measuring
the water loss from so the rate of
transpiration from so this whole bit of
equipment here the whole thing is called
a potometer and essentially all that it
does is it tracks the movement of an air
bubble and then how far that bubble
moves in a certain amount of time gives
us the rate of transpiration so let's
step let's break it down and see what's
going on now first of all what we do is
we have a plant right here so a plant is
held kind of within a bung and all of
these tubes here contain water so here
for example here we have a reservoir of
water that I'll talk about more in a
little bit and here at the bottom we
have a beaker full of water as well so
there's water throughout the whole of
these these tubes here there's an one
air bubble and this air bubble is
extremely important as we'll see in a
minute so what happens is this Jarry
transpiration water is lost from the
leaves now as water is being lost from
the leaves it draws up water so water is
drawn up into the planter because we've
got a constant transpiration stream
going on so water gets drawn up through
to replace the water that's lost from
the leaves so let's think about this
whole series of events a force has been
drawn into the plant
it's going to draw water this way if
what willed has been drawn this way it's
going to draw water up there and now we
get to our air bubble so if all of this
water's being drawn up and through the
plants then this air bubble over time is
also going to move that way
now how we estimate the rate of
transpiration is we need to see how this
air bubble moves over time so let's say
we're going to time our experiment and
we're going to leave it for 10 minutes
on my stop clock down there okay now
what I need to do is this I need to get
a ruler so here's my ruler right here
and I need to measure the distance that
that air bubble moves in how far
straight how far that air bubble moves
in ten minutes so let's say for sake of
argument I've left it 10 minutes and in
10 minutes it's moved 30 millimeters
what I need to do now is I need to
calculate the rate of transpiration so
if it's traveled 30 millimeters in 10
minutes all I need to do is find out how
far it's moved every single minute so
the answer is every single minute it's
traveled three millimeters so what I
need to do after I've done one repeat so
one thing so I've done the experiment
once so I've allowed the bubble to move
once this is where this reservoir of
water and this little thing here this
little tap oops
this little tap comes into play so right
here we have a tap so the whole point of
this reservoir water and tap is really
simple during the actual experiment it's
closed all its use words are open the
tap to allow the water to to flow down
here just to restore the bubble to the
starting position that I want so once
I've done the experiment once I just
open the tap to put the air bubble back
to its starting position and then I can
go again so different things I might
want to be looking at each time I might
change the light intensity so I might
see how the light intensity so the light
that I'm shining on the plant affects
the rate of transpiration my independent
variable the thing that I change might
be the temperature I could change the 10
to see how that affects the rate of
respiration and finally something else I
could change I could change the airflow
so I could see if I've got a fan blowing
on this how does that affect the rate of
transpiration but that essentially is it
the whole piece of equipment is used a
quarter potometer and it's all about
seeing how far the air bubble travels
over a certain period of time and right
there is my rate of transpiration thank
you